now we've been giving you hints
throughout the show and it's finally
time to find out
who our mystery guest is this week all
right let's review the clues
number one well this apprentice hosted a
reality show
number two five grammy nominations
number three he's half of a dynamic duo
so who could it be mystery guest reveal
yourself
those are easy clues it's country music
star john rich of big
and rich we did the democrat version
okay because you have to make it easy
for the democrats john
he also hosts the pursuit with john rich
exclusively
on fox nation john thanks so much for
being with us
yes ma'am surprise i'm glad to be here
thanks for having me on
now i want to start with something a
little different because
i think if my memory serves me right
that your early dream was not
necessarily to become a country star
but to become a team roper for the
for the rodeo okay first of all what is
that and second of all
what would you have done if you weren't
a singer really is that what you have
done what you have done
oh laura you're so citified come on you
don't know what a team roper is so
where i grew up in amarillo texas ain't
a whole lot going on out there
except for cows and combines and
agriculture
and probably one of the coolest things
you could do would be to be a team roper
so
one guy ropes the horns and one guy
ropes the heels they call it heading and
healing
and uh you know you impress all the
girls if you can
head and heal and so i used to stand
outside waiting on the school bus with
my
lariat and i had these plastic steer
horns sticking out of a bale of hay and
i would go one two three wham and throw
it and pull it back
that was my original big dream all right
now you're also a college
football fan we share that in common and
your your song coming to your city
has been the theme for espn's college
game day for
15 seasons so how did that
partnership come about well so you know
big and rich we put out these uh
big high-powered energetic country songs
we got this one
coming to your city and college game day
way back in the day they said hey we're
going to start going town to town
and that new big and rich song is
perfect coming to your city because
that's what we're doing
and we partnered up with espn and man
you look up and cowboy troy and me and
big kenny
15 years of college football man it's
been pretty cool
all right john you have a bar
in your home in nashville that is
legendary okay and you you claim
that you write a lot of your songs there
i want to i want to get proof of that
okay what exactly about that bar
lends to your creativity and to get to
get the juices flowing well so first of
all do i have a bar in my house or do i
have a house
bar that's that's a big debate and you'd
have to come up and see it sometime
you know what you should broadcast this
show from my bar
you've been telling me that let me just
tell everybody watching this
john rich has been telling me the same
thing for about
15 years okay look you're gonna come
we're gonna have a big party it's gonna
be great
and it's like crickets you get nothing
okay so now on national tv
i totally have you okay totally have you
on this
the door's wide open laura anytime you
want to come but i will tell you i do
write a lot of songs there because
it's looking right at downtown nashville
which is music city
and there's so much talent down in that
town you know you understand
not only who's currently there but who
came through prior to that all the
greats came through and
so to sit there have a little redneck
riviera whiskey pull out an old gibson
guitar
it's a pretty inspiring spot to sit all
right
cash and colt
those are your sons they are yeah that's
my two boys there
explain the names okay so they're
they're 9 and 11
cash and cult cash was named after my
all-time favorite
singer-songwriter johnny cash nobody did
it better than johnny cash
and as a songwriter i couldn't resist
the word play
of cash rich i'm like this dude is not
going to have any trouble meeting girls
named cass rich
right so then colt he was named after
america's
greatest gun maker of all time sam colt
so if you put cash and coal together
their nicknames is guns and money okay
i knew it okay i was able to figure that
out pretty easily but i just needed to
hear that from you all right john
it's time for this or that and the game
is pretty simple i'm gonna name two
things
and you just pick whichever you like
better there's no right or wrong answer
all right
we're gonna put 30 seconds up on the
clock and try to get through as many of
these as you can
okay we start now this is easy now
johnny cash or johnny carson
johnny cash the man in black guitar
toilet
or guitar shaped pool i'll take the
guitar shake pool
which is more country texas or tennessee
i would say texas but tennessee helped
us out at the alamo
barbecue texas or tennessee
baby got the smoke you got the smoke in
texas
all right well i was i was actually
gonna go to
one more but we're gonna have to save it
john for your next appearance
john rich john rich i'm glad you didn't
go into roping i'm glad you went into
music
because otherwise we wouldn't be having
so much fun hey thanks so much for
joining us great to see you as always